ANITA WOERNER ORTIZ: I'm proud
to be part of a University
with such an extraordinary history
and I think women play
an incredible role in that.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
ALEXANDRA LEBENTHAL: I am a passionate
and staunch supporter of women
in every way, shape and form.
JENNIFER A. DANIELS: How can we
make a change, how can we bring
people together to unite
for our greater good?
DIANE HASLING: My first real memory
of Princeton is when I was 9.
Our family came to a football
game with my father,
Class of 1952, and on to
Campus Club after.
The sense of camaraderie
and community was amazing
and I decided I wanted
to go to Princeton.
The catch was
Princeton was all male.
Fast forward June 1969.
My father's reading the PAW
and he looks up and said,
guess what, Princeton just
announced that they're
going co-ed. You can apply.
LETTA FRAZIER SNEED: I think
that one of the most startling,
eye-opening moments
for me was not really
when I was here
as an undergraduate.
It was actually in 1993,
a couple of days
before my graduation,
when I did P-rade
for the first time,
and it was the first time that
I saw the parade of classes
go by, which were all men
except for the spouses,
until it got to the
years of co-education,
and it never really dawned
on me in such an impactful way
that co-education was very recent,
basically happened around
the time that I was born,
and so it was such a
stunning visualization for me
just to see it in such a happy,
celebratory way with P-rade.
CAROL OBERTUBBESING: To be a woman at
Princeton in 1969, September of '69,
was actually much more difficult
than I had imagined it to be.
It was the midst of the Vietnam War,
the Civil Rights Movement,
the beginning of the women's
and the LGBTQ movements,
so a lot was happening on campus
and in the world at large.
MARSHA ROSENTHAL: Princeton
launched into admitting women
in the spring of 1969 and
there were a lot of structures
that didn't exist
for women students,
so it was both a challenge
and an opportunity.
And I remember saying to my mother,
I'm going to be a pioneer.
GLADYS J. EPTING: Princeton
opened me up to the world.
I was from a small
Southern town where,
very poor high school
and I was poor.
And the girls in my
high school were required
to take cooking and sewing,
and the boys took shop
where they made a gun rack.
As a female especially
I sort of had to hide
that I was smart or couldn't,
I was frustrated that I didn't
have things I could learn,
things to study.
And then I got to Princeton.
The day I got my admission,
which was April 19, 1971,
I counted that as my birthday.
VICKI TAKEUCHI WYNNE: When I first
got to Princeton, I had a chance
to hear the famous
anthropologist Margaret Mead.
She was speaking to us women
and she said to us,
you women have absolutely
no business being here.
And she continued, because these
men don't have a clue
what to do with you.
NANCY H. LIN: Being a woman
at Princeton during 1973-77,
there was a sense being special,
of doing something new,
of being a pioneer, of
having young women in Princeton
where few women had gone before.
NADIA LINDA CHIU HOLE: I was your
first female chapel watchman,
your first student sex ed
counselor - as a virgin.
ALIYE CELIK: I am proud to be
the first woman to be accepted
to the School of Architecture.
MARJORY GENGLER SMITH: I was a member
of the first women's athletic team,
the women's tennis team.
JEAN TELLJOHANN: The first term when
I was elected as a class officer,
all four of the elected officers
of my class were women,
and that was a Princeton first.
TINA RAVITZ: I was elected to become
the first female president
of The American
Whig-Cliosophic Society.
JILL ROBIN BARON: During my junior year
of Princeton I had the good fortune
of being part of a group
of students and the only female
to interview former President
Gerald Ford in Washington.
And during that interview
I asked President Ford
if he foresaw a woman as
president of the United States.
And believe it or not, I cannot
remember what he said,
but I'm sure he said that
there would be a woman president.
EVE LESSER: I think that being
one of the few women on campus
at the time that I was there
actually served me very well
in my future business
career and provided me
with the benefit that
I didn't at all appreciate
or understand at the
time I was at Princeton.
Namely, as I went off
and worked on Wall Street,
which was at a time that
there were very few women,
I found that I could
sit in a board room
addressing an all-male board
and feel extremely comfortable
because I had already
had that experience
of having to make my voice
heard in an all-male precept.
SUSAN KATZMANN HORNER: To be a woman at
Princeton in the early- to mid-1980s
meant when you looked around
there were two young men
for every one of you,
but I knew the University
was headed in the right direction
in terms of gender equality
because that ratio
actually was better
than what had existed
just a few years
before I had arrived.
KIM GOODWIN: One of the reasons that
I'm so proud of our alma mater
is that over the years
Princeton has done so much
for students who are
just like I was.
Enabling them as first-gen and
low-income students
to become who they
were intended to be.
SHARON FAIRLEY: Although I never
thought about it at the time,
in retrospect I'm almost
certain that my admittance
to Princteon was a
result of affirmative action.
I didn't realize how
unusual it would be
to be a young black woman
in this field of study.
MICHELLE BEEMAN: I remember
Sally Frank had brought her lawsuit
while we were on campus
and challenging the all-male
eating clubs and so there
was definitely a tone
of challenging the past
and challenging history
of Princeton and the fact
that we were one of the last
or the last Ivy to go co-ed maybe,
so it was kind of interesting.
It was also not a time
where you saw GLBT people,
and I came out as a lesbian
after leaving Princeton.
I did not see women on campus,
gay women on campus,
lesbians on campus.
It was just something
that we predated
I think that becoming
part of the campus life.
ANDRIA MIRABAL: To me what makes
Princeton women special is the fact
that women have not
necessarily been on this campus
that long but have
found the right ways
to make themselves known.
And that takes a lot of bravery
and I think it takes a lot
of support from one another,
so I see Princeton women
really going above and beyond
in the support that
they give one another
and the things that
they do to celebrate
being Princeton women,
but also things that they,
again, challenge the University,
that we can still make strides
and improve on these situations.
So making Princeton
a place that is equally
for the women and men
that are here.
EVA LERNER-LAM: In Chinese culture
there is this concept
of opportunity and challenge.
Challenge and opportunity,
it's yin and yang.
Here at Princeton there were
so many opportunities
but even the challenges
represented opportunities.
PATRICIA GRAUE: I learned at Princeton
to take advantage of opportunity,
to go after what I wanted,
to not be afraid to fail,
and to support others,
both in moments of extreme joy
as well as moments of challenge.
SONJA DUMAS: Princeton made me
braver, more courageous.
I had arrived at Princeton
with a lot of bravery,
with a lot of courage
but it made me more so,
the way it enticed me
to investigate, it forced me
to write better, to argue better,
to prove my point
or disprove a point or whatever
it was that I needed to do.
That's what Princeton did for me
and that's the courage,
and that's this confidence
that I carry
as I walk through the world.
JESSICA MELORE: At graduation
I was very honored to receive
the Allen Macy Dulles award
for the student
representing Princeton's motto,
Princeton in the nation's service
and the service of humanity.
But I think that
an award like this
really speaks to Princeton's
culture of service,
not only in encouraging students
from the moment that they enroll,
but also once they graduate,
the many programs that they offer.
And I feel very honored to be part
of that tradition of service.
MARY POTEAU-TRALIE: Princeton is a
place in constant flux, paradoxically,
it's a place that doesn't
change, and in that I mean
that it's a place that never
loses its aspirational nature
of striving to raise us all up
through the best of
what humanity offers.
DONNA CAIN: We are in a time and
we are always in a time
when we need strong female leaders,
and there is no better
place to breed women
of substance and strength
than Princeton University.
TINA MADISON WHITE: As an adult Princeton
taught me that the greatest gift
we can bestow on
others is to welcome
and to know them
for who they are.
My fondest hope for the
women of Princeton is that
we can use our awesome powers
to enrich and release
the lives of countless others
around the world.
SHIKHA UBEROI BAJPAI: We're all
sisters in this together,
I think this is the best part
]about being a Princeton Tiger,
we can help each other forward.
JULIE CHANG: Princeton is
such an incredible place
with so much opportunity
and there's really
no better environment in which
to really thrive and flourish.
LAURA FORESE: And I predict that
women alums will continue
to make our mark on Princeton
and on the world beyond.
MEG GOLDSTEIN FAGAN SCHLEFER: On that final
note I would say thank you to Princeton.
[PIANO MUSIC]